this is a production of Cornell
University
alright thanks Jeff I'm happy to be here
and kick off the seminar series this is
a little different from what i'm doing
now but it's something that I'm very
enthusiastic about so hopefully I can
convey some of the interesting things
that I learned over the course of an
eight-year stint and be so I'm going to
talk about ways that the atmosphere and
the landscape combine or interact to
produce flash floods in the Northeast us
so the structure of my talk will just be
some background on flash floods and then
describe my my study methods and then
talk about the variability in what's
happening in the atmosphere what's
happening in a landscape and then I
define some runoff types that help us
sort of address how how flash floods
work here in the Northeast and then a
separate study that I'll talk about just
briefly is how people influence the the
prevalence of flash floods and then tell
you my conclusions so the definition of
a flood is fairly intuitive for most
people it's where water is and that it
usually isn't so we think of floods like
in the Midwest where acres and acres of
cropland are flooded and it lasts for
months and months and we we can talk
about floods river floods as water where
we don't want it to be it's it's
flooding our cities and our homes and
our our crops and hydrologists talk
about floods in different ways but but
the definition that I'm using is the
weather service definition which is a
flash flood which is a flood that occurs
within six hours of the onset of
whatever caused the flood so in my all
of the floods I'm talking about its
precipitation but it could also be
something like snow melt or
damn break so the flash floods are
different from river floods because
they're they're quick and like the name
sounds they happen quickly and the
inundation might not last very long and
it's difficult to pin down where and
when the flood happened and how long you
know how much area covers and things
like that these are things that are more
routinely characterized for river floods
it's harder to do for flash floods and
since flash floods are generally
reported by people not by gauges or
remote sensing then there's a bias and
where they're reported so they're only
reported if someone notices and calls
and says you know there was a flash
flood here so so so I'll get into a
little more in a bit about how I deal
with these challenges of detecting and
then delineating where flash floods
happen so the motivation for studying
flash floods is fairly simple flash
floods cost lives and money in the
Northeast we see damages in the millions
of dollars every year and unfortunately
people die almost every year in the
Northeast as a result of flash floods
despite the public awareness campaign of
the National Weather Service that you
may have seen the signs turn around
don't drown it's it's a significant
cause of death in terms of
weather-related deaths throughout the US
but as you know I'm focusing on the
Northeast so what causes flash floods
what we already know before I got
started on my work we know that in the
atmosphere we need sufficient water and
energy to produce heavy rainfall so
heavy rainfall could mean either intense
rainfall for a short period of time it
could mean a longer period of time with
less intense rainfall that still results
in a high volume of water in the
landscape we know that higher slopes
lead to more flash floods we know that
certain soil properties that I'll get
into more detail are make a landscape
more susceptible to flooding and when we
pave or in other ways make land area
impervious that it makes it so the water
has nowhere to go so if the if we don't
do a good job in in routing that water
away from homes and and and buildings
and crops and things then the impervious
areas can be a problem because they
generate more runoff and it has no place
to go and cause the flash flood so the
two run off mechanisms that I'm going to
talk about this is this is how
hydrologists understand the conversion
of rainfall to run off so we produce an
atmosphere or some amount of
precipitation and then what happens what
happens is one of two things either the
rate of rainfall exceeds the
infiltration capacity of the soil and
whatever that excess is runs off or if
we have saturated areas in the landscape
than any rain that falls on that
saturated area has nowhere to go so it
can also produce runoff and in the
Northeast saturation excess has been
shown to be the most common runoff
mechanism because our soils have a high
enough infiltration capacity relative to
the rainfall intensity that generally
usually saturation excess is the the
mechanism that causes the runoff that
makes streams run a little higher than
they used to but we'll see flash floods
or a special case and generally we think
of them as extreme events but I'll also
talk a little bit about that that
concept of extreme to okay so
all of the the landscape variables that
contribute to those two types of runoff
are highly variable throughout the
Northeast so we can see a range of
saturated hydraulic conductivity which
I'm using as a proxy for infiltration
rate that ranges by an order of
magnitude the depth of the soil so the
depth either to bedrock or a restrictive
layer or a permanent water table ranges
quite a bit from almost nothing to a
meter and a half and then the slopes in
this area we have coastal plains and
that are basically zero slope and then
we have places in Pennsylvania and New
York that are basically cliffs and and
if you've ever driven in Pennsylvania
you know that the slopes in Pennsylvania
are quite significant and then you can
see a also a great deal of variation in
impervious areas and you can tell just
by looking at this where the people are
you can also see that that contrary to
what an Alaska girl thinks of the
Northeast is you know being all this all
super populated we actually have quite a
few areas in this region that don't have
people in them really very much at all
okay so that's variation in the
landscape some landscape variables also
a variant time as well as space and this
is a picture of the soil moisture
product that I used so you can see the
variability throughout the region but
then also the difference between what
may typically looks like in terms of so
moisture what oddest if eclipse like
little drier everywhere so we've got
time variance as well as phase variance
and then in the atmosphere we have both
space and time variable ability
everybody likes to look at at radar
loops so we're going to go through this
is one of the flash floods that was in
my study so you can see that over time
we have a different so the color ramp is
is
radar reflectivity which is related to
precipitation so you can think of more
red and purple colors as intense
precipitation and more blue and green
colors as less intense precipitation so
the white dot here is where the flash
flood happened so over the course of a
couple of hours that dot goes from
having basically no precipitation to
very intense precipitation to no
precipitation again and here's a
snapshot of what the the intensity
looked like at one particular time for
PM eastern this outline is the watershed
that contributed to the flash flood and
you can see that parts of the watershed
had no rainfall at that time and parts
had very intense 100 millimeters per
hour rainfall so lots of variability in
space and time multiple variables that
we're studying so it's a really
complicated system that I'm trying to
pin down here so my research questions
the ones that I'm going to discuss today
what is the dominant mechanism of runoff
contributing to flash floods in the
Northeast and then I'm also going to
address how human infrastructure affects
flash floods in this region so my data
set consisted of 180 flash flood events
around the Northeast us we chose them
from the NCDC storm events database like
I said we don't have a lot of remote
sense remotely sensed data or instrument
sensed data so we have to go with what
people reported and entered into this
database we looked at the years 2003
through 2007 we stuck with the warm
season so we don't have to deal with
snow melt which anyone who's ever done
any hydrology knows snow melt is very
difficult we also avoided tropical
storms because they behave differently
in the atmosphere and then once we
figured out where these flash floods
happen we defined a watershed for each
flood location so the contributing area
to that flood and then within that
watershed determined the storm and
watershed properties that I just talked
about so just a quick word this is
something that comes up a lot people say
why don't you just
look at where floods happened at USGS
gauges because then you have more
information you know the flow rate you
know the duration of the flood but flash
floods happen on not only faster but
also a smaller scale than USGS gauges so
this is an example again of a flood from
my data set where the flood happened in
this little watershed here so we know
that there was a street here that was
flooded and this is the contributing
area to that street flood the nearest
gauge is here so any any flooding that
might have happened may or may not
actually show up in the hydrograph here
at the gauge so overall in our data set
the this histogram shows the the
watershed area for the dark bars or our
data set the light bars are the USGS
gauges around the active USGS gauges
around the Northeast so the average
watershed size for our data set is about
75 square kilometers and the average for
the USGS gauges is about a thousand so
we're talking about a very different
spatial scale here similarly with remote
sensing remote sensing have gotten very
good at helping us understand where
river floods are happening the degree of
inundation and the timeframe but again
the time and space resolution of these
products isn't it good enough really for
us to identify where flash floods happen
how long they last things like that so
here's a little tour the NCDC storm
events database that's a tiny bit blurry
but so the database you can query it for
a location a date and then the kind of
events that you want to look for so I
filtered by flash floods and in this
example this is tompkins county and 2006
to 2014 and what you get is a list of
the flash floods that occurred during
that time period in that place and you
can see that on some days there were
more than one flood report
so in our data set we only count one we
only considered one flood per day so if
there was more than one flood we took
the worst flood the one with the highest
precipitation depth so when you get into
the results of this database you you see
time and place and sometimes you get in
there's a there's a narrative field
where the person taking the report can
give you more information and sometimes
the information is not very descriptive
it just says ditches overflowed but
sometimes they give you an actual
pinpoint location and this is really
helpful for me as a hydrologist because
I know for sure what watershed or
contributing area was was responsible or
contributing to that flood so we like
those those are the best ones so here's
a map of our 180 events and you can see
some clustering of events in places like
western Pennsylvania down here in the
sort of very populated area around New
York City and some places where we don't
see flash floods like the Adirondacks
and north central Pennsylvania alright
so so once we establish where the flood
happened and like I said it if I can i
pick a location that's an intersection
or a stream crossing or something like
that as my outlet for my watershed if I
can't do that then I take previously
defined basins so they're they're
already delineated by the National
Weather Service and whichever Basin got
the most rain that's the one that I
consider is the contractor that
contributing watershed for the flood so
then I used ArcGIS hydrology tools and a
10 meter DM to delineate the watershed
that contributes to each blood and if
you're familiar with with flow
accumulation
algorithms then I just you be might be
interested to know that our GIS uses an
eight direction algorithm so it assumes
that waterfalls it can flow and one of
it can flow like in the basically the
compass directions ok so for soil
properties I used mostly the sir go soil
database so i got porosity calculated
based on both density the saturated
hydraulic conductivity and all of these
cell properties were averaged over the
watershed and then for soil moisture i
used a land surface model that accounts
for precipitation evaporation soil
properties transpiration and then
calculates what the model is what the
soil moisture would be on a given day
for a four kilometre grid and i use the
top ten centimeters and we consider that
sort of the most hydrologically active
area for the atmosphere the storm
properties we used a radar product that
aggregates rainfall in data into these
polygons that have that are their
hydrologic polygons so they're based on
on actual land surface elevation and we
were able to extract the intensity so
for for my purposes i counted the
maximum five minute rain rate anywhere
in the watershed so even if it rained
you know without looking over that
spatial and temporal variability
whatever the most intense rainfall was
that's the one that i considered and
then similarly wherever in the watershed
there was the most accumulation of
precipitation so a depth we talk about
precipitation and inches or millimeters
wherever that was the highest that was
what I considered the amount of
precipitation for that flood event and
it's sort of it's worth noting that as
an exercise I did do a more detailed
temporal and spatial analysis or model
of the two different runoff types so for
infiltration excess I used to green in
amped equations and said for every 10
meter square every 10 meter grid cell in
a raster what was the sum of the excess
rainfall over the infiltration capacity
summed up over the whole storm and what
would be the the total infiltration
excess runoff from that that calculation
and for saturation I used a model based
on the curve number to say the same
thing for every 10 meter cell for the
whole watershed what was the sum of the
saturation excess runoff based on soil
moisture storage and the rainfall depth
this took me a couple of months to get
all of the products all of the inputs
together for this one watershed so I
needed a method that was less
computationally and and sort of my time
intensive to talk about the different
runoff mechanisms and the flash floods
and our hundred and eighty flood data
set so I came up with these indices
where basically for infiltration XS I
said if the maximum rainfall rate
anywhere in the watershed exceeds the
average case at then saturated hydraulic
conductivity then we're going to call
that the rate ratio so the excess of
rain rate over soil infiltration
capacity which I know saturated
hydraulic conductivity does not equal
soil infiltration capacity but I'm using
it as a proxy similarly if the rainfall
depth exceeds the soil moisture deficit
that's going to be our depth ratio so
the rain depth over the soil moisture
deficit
it and I calculated the soil moisture
deficit as the soil moisture the day
before the event subtracted from the
total soil porosity and then times the
depth of the soil to bedrock or
permanent water table so the results of
these analyses you can see the
variability in the landscape this is the
these histograms are my data set so
before I showed you a map of the whole
northeast this is what my dataset looks
like so the impervious area was
generally less than ten percent slope
was pretty variable but you know around
ten percent was the was the sort of
typical value saturated hydraulic
conductivity typically right around
between fifty and a hundred millimeters
per hour and soil depth right around a
meter typically but some variation in
those and then also quite a bit of
variation in the storm property so again
this is the maximum rate and the maximum
depth for the storm and you can see that
most of the storms were pretty intense
100 millimetres an hour but lots of them
were not very intense so that's
something to keep in mind as we talk
about what's causing flash floods in
this region and I wanted to sort of
point out for for you know reference the
storms in Ithaca so every year we would
expect to see a storm that's around 85
millimeters per hour at some point in
the storm and a total daily accumulation
of about 50 millimeters so that's normal
for a year so just to give you a
reference of where these storms fall
with respect to a normal year so when I
looked at the rain ratio of the rate
ratio and the depth ratio I came up with
these quadrants so basically if the rate
ratio is greater than one I would
expect to see some infiltration excess
runoff and if the cetera if the depth
ratio was greater than one I would
expect to see some saturation excess run
off and then we have these other
quadrants where maybe both runoff
mechanisms are happening and then this
is a very interesting quadrant because
we can't identify either mechanism
happening by my methods but I have some
ideas about why things might be flooding
down in that quadrant so this is how it
breaks down about half of the events
were infiltration excess and
thirty-seven percent can't identify and
three percent saturation excess thirteen
percent both mechanisms are happening so
the spatial distribution of these
mechanisms or combinations of mechanism
the you can see sort of a spread of the
of the mechanisms throughout the region
but then we have these clusters and I
think these clusters are important and
I'll talk about that more in just in
terms of figuring out why flash floods
are happening if for example in this
area if we're seeing both infiltration
excess and saturation excess then we
know that this is an especially
vulnerable area and just the number of
events that are happening in western
Pennsylvania also suggests that it's
vulnerable but why that's the sort of
question that I'm trying to get at here
so why are we having these events here
that have neither especially high rate
ratios or especially high depth ratios
what's going on why is it flooding here
and then in in eastern PA and New Jersey
we're seeing a cluster of events that
happen because of infiltration excess so
we can look at these variables again and
look at the clusters and sort of start
to to develop some hypotheses about why
we
seeing what we're seeing so for example
the sum of the shallow soils in the
Northeast are happening in this
northwestern Pennsylvania area so it
would make sense given my my assertions
here about mechanisms that that
saturation excess would be a likely
mechanism here they're not especially
high hydraulic conductivity so seeing
intense rainfall and and infiltration
excess runoff is not may be too
surprising in the cluster here of
infiltration excess we have a lot of
people living here so you know maybe the
flash floods are happening largely
because of impervious area and
infrastructure but maybe it's because
maybe it's because the saturated
hydraulic conductivity is little a
little low I don't know the this one is
an area where I think there's still a
lot of room for more research just in
terms of like I said developing some
hypotheses based on this this structure
of runoff mechanisms and then testing
them with models or with spatial
statistics okay so we looked at those
histograms of the rate and depth of the
storms in this data set and I was struck
by the fact that many of the events were
not especially intense and many of the
events were not especially high in in
total precipitation depth so i looked at
the return period or the recurrence
interval of the storms that caused these
floods and it turns out that that half
or more of the events are actually quite
common so for the accumulation or the
depth half of them are more at least as
frequent as the five year storm
and more than half in in in terms of
rate so the intensity of the storm more
than half of the storms we're at least
as frequent as the five-year storm so
we're seeing flash floods happening
because of events that are fairly common
so we think of flash floods as an
extreme event but they're actually not
that unusual in terms of the the
probability or the frequency of the
storm that's causing them so what's
going on why are we seeing so many flash
floods in places where where these
storms are not especially uncommon I
think a lot of it has to do with us I
think a lot of it has to do with the
infrastructure that we've built so my
little joke that I it's not even a very
good joke but if a flood happens when
there's no one around was it a flood so
we we really only care about flash
floods when they affect us when they
flood our property when they hurt people
and so there's this bias toward flash
floods that happen in places where
people live paces where people have
paved things and probably developed some
stormwater infrastructure of some kind
to deal with excess water if we
carefully design our stormwater systems
then this could help mitigate flash
floods that's what they're for is to get
the water off the road to get the water
off the parking lot or the places that
it's not supposed to be unfortunately
that doesn't that doesn't always work so
well so what do we do we pave things we
dig ditches we build culverts and
municipal storm water systems and one of
my research projects was looking deeper
into one aspect of this infrastructure
which is called Road culverts and I I
looked at a whole bunch of culverts
in several watersheds in the Hudson
River Valley and I said what's the
capacity of this culvert how much water
can this culvert handle it at its
maximum flow rate and then what storm
would produce that much rainfall too
meta to max out that culverts capacity
oh it's a barrel like metal or plastic
barrel that goes under the road so you
have a ditch an open ditch and then a
pipe and then an open ditch on the other
side so it's like so it serves to get
the water under the road and then it's
an open ditch on the other side so in a
city everything would be underground but
in more rural areas we just have these
open ditches and then the culvert gets
the water under the road okay so we
looked at the capacity of these culverts
how much water can it convey at its
maximum and then which storm return
period would would exceed meet or exceed
that capacity and then i color-coded
them because people like to see simple
ways of visualizing the the results of
this so I actually gave these maps to
the cities or towns that that were in or
close to these watersheds and I said
these dark red culverts are your problem
areas these are the ones that are going
to flood the most frequently and you can
see from this map that quite a few of
them are in the orange and red range
which means that they're likely to be
inundated or exceeded every one or two
years so that sounds like a lot it seems
like a lot of failure and it turns out
that this is actually verified by the
people who live there they say yeah this
culvert backs up Bloods the road every
year or every other year
so it seems kind of extreme but it's
true in some places anyway that these
culverts aren't actually designed for
the amount of runoff that's reaching
them and we don't have good records of
every time this culvert floods because
people only report it if it's extreme or
if they notice or if they care so I know
here in the Ithaca area I talked to
people from Lansing who say their
driveway floods every year or two years
or the ditch fills up and almost hits
the road every year or two years so
we're kind of right on the cusp of
infrastructure failures really
frequently in in a lot of different
places so what can we do about it we can
first of all we can get people to report
these floods or culvert failures more
frequently and that would maybe look
like smartphone pictures uploaded and
sent to the National Weather Service
maybe geotagged so that we'd know
exactly where it was it could be more
like an app where people can you know
put in their intersection where they are
and say no there was a flood here on
this day at this time if we had more
detailed information about this this is
my this is my sort of engineering
remotely calculated way of saying which
culverts are vulnerable but if we could
have actual records of which culverts
are flooding that would be even better
and then we could give that information
to the city planners and they could
decide if they have a little money which
they usually don't but let's say they
get some they can prioritize which
culverts to repair or or upgrade so I
guess the bad news is that it's not
going to get any better so we're
expecting more intense rainfall in the
Northeast and a lot of places in the
world
and rare storms so I already said that
these flush floods are happening because
of not very rare storms but rare storms
are becoming less rare so we're going to
see even more flash floods if my
assessments of why these things are
happening are true and we're seeing that
in a lot of places our infrastructure is
not adequate and it's going to be even
worse as we get more and more rainfall
either more intense or more total
accumulation so maybe that leads to more
floods I yeah so what's all this wrap up
to mean basically I think that I found
evidence for both runoff mechanisms
infiltration excess and saturation
excess infiltration excess seems to
happen more often than in the Northeast
in for flash floods regular storms I
think we can still argue that saturation
act excesses the is the dominant
mechanism but these are special flash
floods are special and so high intensity
rainfall or high accumulation can cause
flash floods depending on the landscape
so it depends on the soil depends on the
the impervious areas and we can see that
not all flash floods require especially
intense or especially high accumulation
rainfall which is important because a
lot of research into flash floods is
looking at these intense storms and I'm
saying that we need to be looking at the
landscape too and look at places that
are vulnerable due to soil properties
due to slopes and impervious areas and
if we consider all of these landscape
properties while we're talking about
vulnerable areas then we and and also
find a way to talk about this time and
space variable soil moisture which is
difficult but find a way to incorporate
that into our assessments of the
susceptibility of any given watershed
then we're going to be better prepared
to
forecast when and where flash floods are
going to happen and then I found that
runoff types are spatially clustered and
of course where we build stormwater
infrastructure how well we design it
matters a lot it depends I mean it
affects a lot how when and where flash
floods are going to happen so research
this still needs to happen I think like
I said the the clustering of these
runoff types is is provocative and I
think a lot of work could still be done
on figuring out what the causes are why
these runoff types are clustering in
geographic areas and then this can help
us get to is a particular area more
susceptible to high intensity rainfall
or high depth or maybe it's acceptable
to both or maybe we need to start
looking at reasons why small not very
rare storms are causing flash floods in
a given area and then I think it would
be interesting to do more in depth case
studies like the one that I did at the
10 meter resolution just to get an idea
of any given watershed you could say you
know this watershed is more likely to
have infiltration access or saturation
excess runoff and again the more we
understand what's going on in the
landscape the better we can prepare for
the witch storms are going to be likely
to cause flash floods in in that in that
area so thanks to my collaborators Todd
Walter Steve kluchi and Steve Jessup and
funding from the NSF and thank you for
listening to me and I have time for
questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu